c'était la dernière répétition de la
chorale qui va participer à la messe
papale dans la capitale albertaine en
tout c'est plus de 65 choristes
provenant de différentes paroisses et
chorale de l'alberta qui vont chanter
devant près de 70000 personnes mardi
avant midi pour la coordonnatrice de la
chorale la musique est inévitable pour
avancer envers ce processus de
réconciliation pour - sais c'est que la
musique peut guérir et c'est vrai pour
tous les gens qui sont humains que la
musique guéri et donc c'est notre nous
espérons que la musique que nous
chantions la main ce sera une source de
guérison de réconciliation
l'esprit de leurs du pèlerinage
les choristes vont chanter engrais qui
crie latin français mais majoritairement
en anglais
[Musique]
4-1 ou bâcher franco albertaine et
choristes professionnels depuis près de
trente ans pour elle chanté lors de la
messe papale est tout un honneur c'est
quelque chose qui permet un trajet vers
une réconciliation pour les peuples qui
en ont besoin et c'est non seulement les
peuples autochtones c'est la société
canadienne si chanter dans une chorale
puisse aider à développer une récole
situation s'est vraiment on ne peut pas
dire non lorsqu'on reçoit l'invitation
la chorale chantera lors de la messe
papale qui aura lieu à 10 heures au
stade du commonwealth dan mountain le
mardi 26 juillet à tous ceux qui ne
possèdent pas de billet vous pourrez
visionner la célébration en direct sur
toutes les plateformes de radio-canada
ici ndi à la faune radio canada edmonton